Hey, what's popping. Hey guys. Hey, I'm Joe ma I'm Joe, take a look at me. Look,
this is Joe Mer 100,000 subscribers. See,
I think you guys should subscribe to my channel and tackle it.
You should subscribe to tackle it too. Hey, by the way, my name Jeremy look,
I'm so cool. I think I'm so funny. Look, everyone I'm depressed.
I'm so depressed. [inaudible]
isn't that cool? That's the only thing I can do. Look, I'm a,
I'm a data scientist. See the Coquitlam as a data scientist.
I work in Silicon Valley. Okay. What's popping. Get data science.
Okay. It's about influence.
It's about being influential and data. Science is hard.
I'm the only person who seems to know how to do data science.
Now you guys should take a look at this is X a mirror, so you can see
what's that noise.
I thought I told you to be quiet. I'm trying to do a blog here.
My viewers demand quality and quality is what they will get.
No. Where was that?
How's my hair. How's that work, but I still look good. Yeah.
Want to make sure that I still look good so that I can do my flux here where
we're we what's that giving you? Let's take a look at how I look at the mirror.
It looks pretty good though. I really like the way my hair looks. Yeah,
it's nice.
[Inaudible]
okay. Wow. It's been a while.
I'm pretty rusty. So I'm going to get my iPad,
going to look at my notes. Okay.
All right. So the first thing that I want to say is that, um, I'm okay.
You know, I'm not dead.
A lot of you thought it was dead, but I'm definitely okay. You know, I'm,
I'm alive and, um, yeah, so you could stop worrying about me,
but, uh, I just want to say thank you so, so much for, for everyone. Uh,
I know in the last video, you know, I was pretty depressed and stuff like that,
but, um, I'm, I'm, I'm very happy now. I'm very okay.
And I was very surprised in how much you guys cared and it was actually
quite touching and, uh, yeah, like a lot of, a lot of people reached out to me.
Uh, like even some YouTubers, they all reached out to me to see if I was okay.
So I'm super thankful for that. I really appreciate it. And,
um, yeah, honestly, it's one of the reasons why, you know, I got better.
So that's, that's really cool if you guys, so, um,
yeah, so I guess the title of this video was, um,
why that I stopped making videos. Well, as you know, you know,
I had like a burnout,
so th that was definitely a factor and I really needed to take some time to
think about, you know, what I really wanted to do with my life, my career,
with the videos going forward. And, and yeah, and,
and the reason why I had to think about all that was because, you know, I was,
you know, cause I had that catalyst and that catalyst was, you know,
the burnout and that catalyst really made me think about, you know,
my life in general.
And I had to rethink some things and basically, um,
it was kind of bad at the beginning because I had a lot of negativity going on
in my life that I was kind of imposing on myself,
some negativity and it was starting to turn kind of like a vicious cycle.
I don't know if you guys ever had this thing where it's like, Oh, you know,
for example, you're sad about one thing. And then because of that thing,
you're sad about another thing. And then it gets worse and worse.
So I realized that, and then, yeah,
like I was very sad and I had to fix myself before that spiral
goes into something worse.
And one of the things I had to do was to take a break and that means, you know,
videos and other stuff.
And I want to focus on my mental health to remove a lot of these stressors.
So I don't need to think about them.
So I could kind of look at my life at a more holistic view and that's pretty
much what I did.
So that's why I did not make videos for awhile because not going to lie,
that was kind of a stressor at that time. And,
um, and a lot of you, you know, thanks for caring. And you wanted to know like,
how did I get out this rut? Or like, you know,
how did I not be sad anymore? Um,
yeah. I mean, there's no simple answer for that.
I think you truly have to find out for yourself some inner
issues that you have that you haven't solved yet. Unfortunately for me,
it's quite personal, so I'm not really like super comfortable sharing it.
If you guys, I know I'm a YouTuber, but you know, there are some limits. And,
but then also like, while I was in that state,
there's also a time aspect to it. Like a lot of you guys told me that, you know,
a lot of people went through it and they told me that's not permanent. And,
and, and they're right, it's not permanent. And, um, basically, you know,
time does heal, you know, and.
Yeah.
Anyway. Yeah. So time does heal.
And it.
And yeah, so yeah, so it's, it's not permanent and time heals,
but you also have to be kind of proactive into like trying to figure out why
you're in a rut and stuff like that. I mean, for me, at least that's what I did.
So because I had to be proactive, you know,
I did a lot of things that to try to help myself, you know, I went to therapy,
I ran, I went to the gym a lot, you know, cause you know,
I read internet articles. I'm like, how, how do I stop being sad?
And a lot of the times that's what they tell you to do. So is that all right?
You know, so I started doing all of these things, you know,
I stopped making videos. I kept moving.
I tried to create better relationships with my friends and then be more social,
always keep moving.
Like it was really hard in the beginning cause you really don't want to do that.
You really don't want to do that, but I still did it, you know, because could,
cause I knew that it was going to be helpful in some ways or at least my
therapist told me, you know, and um, also watched a lot of anime. Uh,
I think that helped, you know, I watch a lot of anime, you know,
in case you're curious, it's uh, I watched a hero acadamia food Wars.
I'm also watching anatomy stuff too. Like Tara's house.
Uh.
What else did I watch? Well, I watched psyche K psyche K is pretty like a,
that was pretty funny.
Uh, yeah, lots of anatomy anyways.
Um,
and then after all that I kind of came. So then.
After all that,
I came to the conclusion that there was like a misalignment between my
actions and my values, which was probably why it wasn't that happy.
Like I could talk about that maybe sometimes in the future,
but probably not now. And um, yeah, like, um, I,
I may talk about it a little bit in the future,
but because now I kind of want to talk about, you know,
switch gears and talk about something, something more positive, which is, um,
you know, what's next, what's next with me? Well,
what's next with this channel mostly. Um,
I just want to say that a startup series,
a lot of people are waiting for a startup series. I will continue that. I mean,
I do enjoy filming it. I love it making it, but it does take a lot of time.
So I mean, I still have a lot of ideas in the back of my mind and um,
I'm very excited, you know, whenever I sleep thinking about that.
So it's definitely, it's definitely coming hopefully.
And then as for the other videos, um, yeah,
like in general there are probably going to be less videos coming out.
Like I'll, I'll probably still make videos, but just less than before,
because I don't want to make videos just for the sake of making videos,
you know? I mean, it's just, it's just less fun and then I'm pretty sure,
like it's less entertaining also. So I'm, so I'm just gonna, you know,
take my time more and making videos and um, yeah, because you know,
I have a lot of other things that I want to do right now that I haven't done
before. So, so I might, yeah.
So I just can't spend that much time on videos.
So anyways. Okay. What about,
what about what's next in my life?
So I am going to continue what I'm doing now, which was like, um, you know,
getting a lot of social interactions and just being more sociable with
developing my friendships and relationships.
I think that's pretty important for me right now and I'm pretty happy doing it,
so I'll probably prioritize that and then I'll have
also like other stuff going on in my life, some change and stuff like that,
but I decided to keep my life a little bit more private, you know, just for,
for some boundaries.
I think that is kind of important if we want to make this sustainable. So yeah.
Yes. Anyways, so that's pretty much it, so yeah.
Thanks so much again. Um, I really, really appreciate it. Every single comment,
I almost read everything. Okay. Okay. I lied, but I read a lot of comments,
you know, from, um, from the previous videos and I was so grateful and yeah,
very wholesome. Yeah. I really enjoyed it. And um, I really appreciate it.
And uh, thank you. Thank you guys so much again, uh, I'm not very good at,
at making at saying these things, honestly, I'm like an awkward guy, but uh,
I want to say is that you can stop messaging like son,
me or my brother or like my UCOR everyone that's like around me,
if I'm okay or if I'm alive. So, um, yeah, thank you. But uh, yeah,
no need to message them anymore. You know, I am AOK, I'm actually very,
very good. I'm actually even happier than before. I'm actually at a really,
really good state now, so yeah. It's pretty dope anyways.
That's pretty much it. So yeah.
Gucci, Gucci.
Oh yeah. And I quit my job.